ONE-ON-ONE WITH OUR RADICAL FAR
LEFT NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO AND HIS
OPINIONS ON BLOOMBERG AND
BERNIE SANDERS BUT WE START
TONIGHT IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTIES IN A
STATE OF SHAMBLES.
251 DAYS UNTIL YOU, WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU WILL BE THE
ULTIMATE JURY, YOU WILL RENDER
YOUR VERDICT.
DEMOCRATS ARE IN THE MIDST OF A
FULL-BLOWN POLITICAL CRISIS.
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE WAS A
NATIONAL EMBARRASSMENT.
THE CANDIDATES ON STAGE FRANKLY
JUST MADE FOOLS OF THEMSELVES.
THEY SCREAM, SHOUTED, LAD,
COMPLAINT, WINEED, THEY LOST
ALL SENSE OF ANY CONTROL,
"THE DAILY BEAST" CALLING IT A
TRAIN WRECK.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
BOARD COMPARING THAT TO A
DUMPSTER FIRE.
EVEN DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
DEBBIE DINGELL REFERRED TO IT AS
A DISGRACE.
IT’S HER PARTY.
IN THE NATION WROTE THAT THERE
WERE NO WINNERS, ONLY
SURVIVORS.
IN CASE YOU MISSED ALL THE FUN,
HERE’S A PERFECT RECAP OF LAST
NIGHTS DEMOCRATIC DEBACLE
DEBATE.
TAKE A LOOK.
[ALL SPEAKING OVER EACH OTHER]
>> BERNIE, BERNIE.
SENATOR KLOBUCHAR --
>> NEW TOPIC.
IF YOU COULD HONOR THE RULES OF
THE DEBATE, THANK YOU.
>> Sean: IT WAS PRETTY MUCH
LIKE THAT ALL NIGHT BUT DURING
THE RARE OCCASION WHEN THESE
PETULANT LOSERS WERE ABLE TO SAY
IF YOU WANT UNINTERRUPTED WORDS,
IT WAS EVEN WORSE.
THE CLEAR FRONT RUNNERS
BERNIE SANDERS BEER LAST NIGHT
THE OLD SOVIET STYLE
SOCIALIST REALLY GOT BACK TO HIS
COMMUNIST ROUTES.
HE DIDN’T HAVE A SINGLE POSITIVE
THING TO SAY ABOUT AMERICA BUT
ONCE AGAIN HE GOES OUT OF HIS
WAY TO PRAISE CUBA’S OPPRESSIVE
SOCIALIST GOVERNMENT, THE ONE
WHERE THEY KILLED PEOPLE, STOLE
THEIR PROPERTY AND PUT ALL
CITIZENRY IN POVERTY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT I SAID IS WHAT
BARACK OBAMA SAID IN TERMS OF
CUBA.
THE CUBA MADE PROGRESS ON
EDUCATION.
[AUDIENCE BOOING]
>> REALLY?
WHAT I SAID IS WHAT BARACK OBAMA
SAID, THAT THEY MADE GREAT
PROGRESS ON EDUCATION AND
HEALTH CARE.
THAT WAS BARACK OBAMA.
AND DICTATORSHIP, WHETHER IT IS
THIS THE CHINESE, OR THE CUBANS,
DO SOMETHING GOOD, YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
>> Sean: NOW HE IS THE CLEAR
FRONT RUNNER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
THIS IS A LIFELONG GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEE.
THREE HOUSES, DESPISES
CAPITALISM, HATES EVERYONE WHO
IS SUCCESSFUL, PRAISES
COMMUNISM, VILIFIES SUCCESS AND
ASSOCIATES WITH SOME OF THE MOST
VILE ACTIVISTS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
FOR EXAMPLE, KNOWN BIGOT, HERE
SHE IS COMING NATIONAL SURROGATE
FOR BERNIE SANDERS.
SHE IS A DESPICABLE ANTI-SEMITE.
SHE SUPPORTS SHARIA LAW, PRAISES
LOUIS FARRAKHAN OF THE NATION OF
ISLAM, RABID ANTI-SEMITE AND
RACIST.
BLAMES HER NEGATIVE IMAGE ON THE
JEWISH MEDIA.
IT’S NO WONDER BERNIE DIRECT SO
MUCH VITRIOL TOWARDS ISRAEL.
AT THE DEBATE HE EVEN CALLED
ISRAEL’S GOVERNMENT RACIST AND
BERNIE IS A WALKING TALKING
78-YEAR-OLD DISASTER FOR THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY PURITY
REPRESENTS WHAT IS THE UGLY
TRUTH ABOUT JUST HOW RADICAL,
HOW EXTREME THIS NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME.
NOW, THE MOB AND THE MEDIA ARE
WORRIED.
DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
MIGHT BE TOTALLY UNELECTABLE.
WE COULD’VE TOLD YOU THAT BEFORE
THIS ALL STARTED.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS NEW SHOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTED WITH
BERNIE’S ANSWER ON THE SOCIALISM
QUESTION.
HE HAD TO KNOW THAT WAS COMING.
>> THE QUESTION ABOUT CUBA.
HE WILL CONTINUE TO GIVE THAT
ANSWER THAT HE GAVE TO YOU, HE
WILL GIVE IT AGAIN TONIGHT AND
THEN HE DIG HIMSELF A DEEPER
HOLE.
>> BERNIE SANDERS DID NOT SEEM
TO BE QUIET AT THE TOP OF HIS
GAME TONIGHT, HE JUST SEEMED A
LITTLE BIT OFF.
>> BERNIE SANDERS, THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME HE GOT ROUGHED UP A
LITTLE BIT AND HE DIDN’T LIKE
IT.
IT SEEMED LIKE HE HAD A COLD.
>> HE WAS RATTLED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN ANY OF THESE DEBATES.
>> Sean: NOW DEMOCRATS ARE
DESPERATELY SEARCHING FOR PLANS
A, B, C.
QUID PRO QUO JOE WAS RUNNING ON
FUMES.
IF HE DOESN’T WIN BAKE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA WE CAN PRETTY
MUCH THAT HIS CAMPAIGN IS OVER
BUT SO FAR, QUID PRO QUO JOE HAS
UNDERPERFORMED IN EVERY SINGLE
CONTEST TO DATE.
ONE SIMPLE REASON, HE IS A
HORRIFIC CANDIDATE.
LET’S FORGET ABOUT THE BAGGAGE
FOR A MOMENT.
LET’S FOCUS ON SOMETHING ELSE,
JOE 30330, HE’S OBVIOUSLY
STRUGGLING.
IF HE EVER HAD A FASTBALL, HE
LOST IT.
IF HE HAD EVER A SOFTBALL HE
LOST THAT TOO.
HE CAN BARELY GET OUT OF SENATE
BEFORE HE LOSES HIS TRAIN OF
THOUGHT.
THE FITS OF ANGER, BIZARRE
LIMITS OF AGITATION ARE PRETTY
TROUBLESOME AND BY THE WAY, HE
SEEMED COMPLETELY INCAPABLE OF
RECALLING BASIC, FUNDAMENTAL
FACTS LIKE, OH, I’M RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT NOT THE SENATE.
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE, WE GOT
ANOTHER EXAMPLE DURING A VERY
BIZARRE, STRANGE, INEXPLICABLE
RANT, JOE CLAIMED THAT
150 MILLION AMERICANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED BY GUNS SINCE 2007.
LET’S DO THE MATH.
150 MILLION.
THAT WOULD BE HALF THE U.S.
POPULATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> 150 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
KILLED SINCE 2007 WHEN BERNIE
VOTED TO EXEMPT THE GUN
MANUFACTURERS FROM LIABILITY.
MORE THAN ALL THE WARS,
INCLUDING VIETNAM, FROM THAT
POINT ON.
CARNAGE ON OUR STREETS.
>> Sean: QUID PRO QUO JOE
CLEARLY NOT UP TO THE TASK OF
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, MUCH LESS
ACTUALLY SERVING AS PRESIDENT.
THAT IS A SCARY THOUGHT.
MEANWHILE, BILLIONAIRE MICHAEL,
YES, MANY MIKE FORMER BLOOMBERG
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
DEMOCRATS’ PLAN B.
LET’S SAY IT’S NOT GOING VERY
WELL.
LET’S SAY, THE NEW YORK EXPERT
FROM NEW YORK DELIVERED ANOTHER
HORRIFIC DEBATE PERFORMANCE
DURING A PRETTY REVEALING
FREUDIAN SLIP.
BLOOMBERG ACTUALLY BOASTING THAT
HE BOUGHT THE DEMOCRATICALLY
CONTROLLED HOUSE.
WOW, HE THINKS HE CAN BUY
ANYTHING.
AMAZING, TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET’S GO ON THE RECORD.
THEY TALK ABOUT 40 DEMOCRATS, 21
OF THOSE WITH PEOPLE I SPENT
$100 MILLION TO HELP ELECT.
ALL THE NEW DEMOCRATS THAT CAME
IN AND PUT NANCY PELOSI IN
CHARGE AND GAVE THE CONGRESS THE
ABILITY TO CONTROL THIS
PRESIDENT, I GOT THAT.
>> Sean: MINI MINI MIKE -- HE CA
BUY SLICK POLITICAL ADS BUT NOT
CHARISMA, PERSONALITY OR A
COHERENT AGENDA THAT WILL
RESONATE WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
OH, YOU’RE 95 COMING OF CANCER,
GOODBYE, GO HOME TO YOUR FAMILY.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
YOU, WE CAN’T AFFORD THAT.
THERE’S NO AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY
CAN PURCHASE A PERSONAL
CONNECTION WITH THE VOTERS.
THAT IS WHY BOLSHEVIK BERNIE IS
WINNING IN THE POLLS.
IT IS NOW BERNIE’S RACE TO LOSE.
GOD HELP US, WHOEVER GETS THE